"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings"
tells a complete, self-contained origin story
while also setting up future adventures
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Not everything is neatly tied
up at the end of the story. Here
are some of the biggest unanswered
questions left open by "Shang-Chi."
Perhaps the worst kept secret
about "Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings" was the involvement
of Ben Kingsley as Trevor Slattery,
who first entered the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in 2013's "Iron Man 3."
"I wouldn't go in there for twenty minutes."
If Ben Kingsley's red carpet arrivals didn't
make it clear, his surprise appearance at
the "Shang-Chi" press conference solidified
it. His role wasn't a mere bit part, either:
Trevor proved critical to the plot, and our
heroes could never have found Ta-Lo without him.
While the audience sees what happens
to Shang-Chi, Katy, and Xialing,
Trevor just kind of vanishes. He survives
the attack of the so-called "soul-suckers"
by playing dead, which might be the greatest
performance of the desperate actor's career.
But what about us, the audience? We never
learn if he stayed in the village, if he
left with Shang-Chi and the gang, or began his
own acting troupe among the residents of Ta-Lo.
Sir Ben Kingsley is one of
the best parts of the film,
so here's hoping we don't have to wait another
seven years to find out what happened to him.
"And you'll never see me coming."
One of the last things we hear before
the credits roll is that Xialing is at
her father's base to dismantle his operations.
Then, the post-credits scene reveals that Xialing
did indeed show up at the Ten Rings base, but
most certainly did not dismantle it. Instead,
she takes the throne herself as men
and women train in the courtyard,
seemingly preparing themselves to take
down whatever targets Xialing may select.
We're promised the Ten Rings will
return, which means that one way
or another we'll get a definitive answer to
what Xialing plans on doing with her new crew.
We don't know whether she was always
lying about taking apart her dad's toxic
infrastructure, or if she just had a
potentially sinister change of heart.
We also don't know how noble she'll be in her
new role. Although her story in "Shang-Chi"
seemed to end in a positive place, she's still
now lost both of her parents. There's no telling
how that may have affected her outlook.
Did Xialing's underground fighting outfit
The Golden Daggers Club get folded into this new
business venture? We'll have to wait to find out.
Shang-Chi and Katy are best friends, and have
such natural chemistry that Katy's own grandmother
asks when the two are going to get married. At
no point in the movie is any kind of romantic
relationship discussed or even really
implied between them -- and yet their
story still follows something resembling
a traditional "friends-to-lovers" arc.
The only thing is, they never officially
become lovers. By the end of the movie they
are walking arm-in-arm with each other, and
certainly seem closer than when they started.
Is that the only hint we get about their
relationship status? What exactly is their deal?
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings"
director Destin Daniel Cretton addressed this
point during a "Shang-Chi" press conference
attended by Looper. When asked if Shang-Chi
and Katy were meant to be best friends
or potential love interests, he asked,
"Aren't all friendships potential love interests?"
He went on to say that the relationship between
Shang-Chi and Katy was written as being intimate,
caring, but also strictly platonic. But
he also said there's another reason why
Shaun and Katy don't end their adventure with
a big romantic smooch. As the director put it,
"It also just naturally felt like the only way
to go with this movie, because Shang-Chi is so
deep in his own inner struggle. I don't think
there's emotional space for anything else."
What's left unanswered is what happens next -—
after all, Shang-Chi's arc in the movie is him
finally coming to terms with his upbringing
and inner turmoil. Now that he's got a little
more emotional space, will these two stay
friends forever, or become something more?
Fittingly, "Shang-Chi and the Legend of
the Ten Rings" begins with a legend. We
start with the story of Wenwu using
his powers to conquer his enemies,
while the narration speculates
about the origin of the rings.
Possibilities like the rings being found in a
cave are mentioned, but nothing is ever declared
the truth — and that's the sum total of what we
know about the MCU-official origins of his power.
In the comics, the rings arrived on
Earth many years ago with Fin Fang Foom,
the extraterrestrial, shape-shifting
lizard-dragon-alien thing who may or
may not be present in "Shang-Chi" in the
form of the giant monster that kills Wenwu.
The Mandarin tore his spaceship apart looking for
artifacts, and that's how he got his ten rings.
But none of this is mentioned in the movie,
and we are told that Wenwu, aka The Mandarin,
has possessed these rings for ten lifetimes. So,
were they the result of some kind of 11th-century
treasure hunt? Was Wenwu seeking them out? We
know at the end that the rings have some kind of
beacon — were they reaching out to him? Or were
they reaching out to somewhere in outer space,
calling for some alien force to
come to Earth and come after them?
It's almost certain that we'll learn more about
the lineage of the Ten Rings at some point.
But as for how Wenwu found them in the
first place? That remains to be seen.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about "Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.